one two ready go  this is gonna be real  mobley  [Music]  it's a winner  the second shot  evan mobley  wins it for team cash i told you the  cash  [Laughter]  [Applause]  oh cleveland we live on location hey  give him rookie of the year now  give evan mobley the trophy now you  might as well present it to him right  now  oh  [Laughter]  oh  man  wow all right that was fun that was good  wait  that was like coach like when coach come  in red you say if you guys hit this shot  you can get out of practice that's right  that's what that felt like right there  or at the end of practice if you all  make this half floor sure you got to  come in tomorrow you gotta come at one  day gotta come in come in late before  the game you don't have to do shoot  around no shoot around no shoot around  all right let's send it down to public  address announcer  mark mason with the winning team